>>> ELON MUSK RATHER SUBTLE IN
SLAMMING ADVERTISERS FOR
ABANDONING X AFTER HE ENDORSED
AN ANTI-SEMITIC POST ON THE
PLATFORM.
>> IF SOMEBODY'S GOING TO TRY TO
BLACKMAIL ME WITH ADVERTISING,
BLACKMAIL ME WITH MONEY, GO
[ BLEEP ] YOURSELF.
BUT GO [ BLEEP ] YOURSELF.
IS THAT CLEAR?
I HOPE IT IS.
>> KIND OF SEEMS LIKE HE WANTED
MORE OF A REACTION SO HE TRIED
IT AGAIN WITH THE AUDIENCE
THERE.
IT ALL HAPPENED LAST NIGHT
DURING THAT LIVE AUDIENCE
INTERVIEW WITH ANDREW ROSS
SORKIN AT "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
DEAL SUMMIT.
MUSK DID APOLOGIZE FOR ENDORSING
ANTI-SEMITIC POST CALLING IT
THE WORST AND DUMBEST SOCIAL
MEDIA POST HE'S EVER DONE.
JOINING US NOW CNN CONTRIBUTOR
KARA SWISHER.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US THIS
MORNING.
I GUESS HE GOT THE CHUCKLE ON
THE SECOND HE WAS LOOKING FOR IN
THAT STATEMENT.
>> I GUESS.
>> IT'S FASCINATING TO ME,
THOUGH, AS WE WATCH THIS, RIGHT,
AND HE'S THERE ON THE STAGE, AND
HE SEEMS TO REALLY BE ENJOYING
THE MOMENT, WE HAVE THIS
ESTIMATE THAT FROM "THE NEW YORK
TIMES", I BELIEVE, THAT HE'S
GOING TO LOSE $75 MILLION IN
REVENUE.
AND HE'S SORT OF SAYING, FINE,
WE DON'T NEED YOU.
BUT THE BUSINESS ITSELF NEEDS
THEM, AND THEY'RE GOING AWAY
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE DID.
>> YES, YES, HE'S -- LET ME JUST
UNDERSCORE FOR THE AUDIENCE,
HE'S 52 YEARS OLD.
THIS IS A 52-YEAR-OLD MAN WHO
FEELS THE NEED TO SAY DIRTY
WORDS TO MAKE PEOPLE SHOCKED.
IT'S JUST -- IT'S BIZARRE AND HE
CAUSED THE PROBLEM, AND HE WANTS
TO BLAME THEM FOR EXERCISING
THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT NOT
TO ADVERTISE ON HIS TERRIBLE
PLATFORM, I THINK.
IT'S REALLY BIZARRE.
IT WAS A BIZARRE PERFORMANCE.
IT WAS A MELTDOWN.
HE SEEMED -- HE ATTACKED BOB
IGER WHO WAS IN THE AUDIENCE,
THE HEAD OF DISNEY FOR JUST NOT
WANTING TO ADVERTISE ON HIM.
IT WAS SO STRANGE, AND HE'S DONE
IT BEFORE.
HE'S ATTACKED ADVERTISERS WHEN
HE FIRST BOUGHT THE COMPANY
BECAUSE HE WAS FRUSTRATED, BUT
AGAIN, LET ME UNDERSCORE, HE'S
52 YEARS OLD AND THE RICHEST
PERSON IN THE WORLD, AND I'M
SORRY HE'S -- THAT'S NOT HOW
ADULTS BEHAVE.
IT'S HOW ADULT TODDLERS BEHAVE.
>> AND ALSO, CERTAINLY NOT HOW
PUBLIC COMPANY -- HEADS OF
PUBLIC COMPANIES BEHAVE.
ONE OF THE DRIVERS OF HOW THAT
PUBLIC COMPANY IS S SUPPOSED TO
SURVIVE IS THE ADVERTISING, THE
PERSON RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
ADVERTISING CAME OVER WITH MUCH
FANFARE, LINDA YACCARINO.
I'M STRUCK, SHE PUT OUT A TWEET
LAST NIGHT, I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
WAS TRYING TO DO TO BE
COMPLETELY CANDID WITH YOU,
SAYING HERE'S MY PERSPECTIVE
WHEN IT COMES TO ADVERTISING.
>> NEITHER DO I.
>> X IS STANDING AT A UNIQUE AND
MAIN INTERSECTION AND THE X
COMMUNITY IS POWER AND FEEL HERE
TO WELCOME YOU.
TO OUR PARTNERS WHO BELIEVE IN
OUR MEANINGFUL WORK, THANK YOU.
IT'S LIKE A TWEETING THROUGH IT
BUT NOT REALLY SURE WITH WHAT
CAPACITY.
>> SHE'S -- DID YOU WATCH
SUCCESSION?
>> YEAH.
>> THE PAIN SPONGE, THAT'S WHAT
SHE IS.
SHE'S THE PAIN SPONGE FOR THIS
BEHAVIOR.
THIS IS AN EXPERIENCED AD EXEC.
SHE KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
HERE.
FOR SOME REASON SHE'S DECIDED TO
ENABLE HIM.
THAT'S THE REAL PROBLEM HERE.
BESIDES HIS RIDICULOUS BEHAVIOR
AND CHILDISH BEHAVIOR, SHE'S
ALSO ENABLING HIM AND MAKING
EXCUSES AND TRYING TO WRAP IT IN
THE CLOAK OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
IN FACT, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ADVERTISE WHERE YOU DON'T WANT
TO.
I THINK THAT'S PRETTY MUCH THE
BASICS OF ADVERTISING.
PEOPLE PICK AND CHOOSE, AND
THEY'VE PICKED, AND INSTEAD HE
WANTS TO BLAME THEM FOR HIS OWN
BEHAVIOR.
IT WAS SUCH A BIZARRE -- IT'S
NOT BIZARRE, HE'S DONE IT
BEFORE.
HE JUST KEEPS DOING IT AND KEEPS
DOUBLING DOWN, AND SO, YOU KNOW,
AT ONE POINT, YOU KNOW, AS MAYA
ANGELOU SAYS WHEN SOMEONE TELLS
YOU WHO THEY ARE, BELIEVE THEM.
>> IN THE GRAND SCHEME OF THINGS
SORT OF ON BRAND.
I WAS ALSO STRUCK BY ISRAEL'S
PRESIDENT WAS ALSO INTERVIEWED
AT DEAL BOOK, AND HE WAS ASKED
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE VISIT
THAT ELON MUSK MADE.
HE WAS ALSO ASKED -- HE SAID HE
APPRECIATED IT, BUT HE WAS ASKED
WHETHER HE THOUGHT ELON MUSK
WOULD ACTUALLY BE FIGHTING
ANTI-SEMITISM ON X, AND HE
DIDN'T REALLY GIVE AN ANSWER,
WHICH TO ME TOLD US EVERYTHING
WE NEEDED TO KNOW.
>> HOW COULD HE.
RIGHT, HOW COULD HE.
IT'S BECOME, YOU KNOW, HE'S
ALLOWED ALL KINDS OF -- HE GOT
RID OF CONTENT MODERATION.
HE SAID EVERYONE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO SAY WHATEVER.
THAT TRIP WAS A PR STUNT, AND IT
WAS -- A LOT OF PEOPLE IN ISRAEL
THOUGHT IT WAS SHAMEFUL FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO DO THAT, BUT THEY
NEED HELP TOO I GUESS, YOU KNOW.
WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE,
ESPECIALLY NETANYAHU.
NETANYAHU HAS COME TO HIS AID
BEFORE WHEN HE HAD ANOTHER ISSUE
AROUND ANTI-SEMITISM WITH THE
ADL, AND SO THIS JUST HAPPENS
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND WHAT'S FASCINATING IS THE
BLAME HE WANTS -- THE RICHEST
MAN IN THE WORLD WANTS TO SAY
ADVERTISERS ARE THE CAUSE OF HIS
PROBLEMS.
HE'S THE CAUSE OF HIS PROBLEMS,
AND THE REASON ADs ARE DOWN IS
BECAUSE OF HOW HE BEHAVES ON THE
PLATFORM, NOT JUST PROMOTING
ANTI-SEMITIC STUFF OR ALLOWING
IT TO RUN RAMPANT, STUDY AFTERDY
SHOWS THIS.
BUT HE SUES PEOPLE OR HE CUTS
THEM OFF OR HE CALLS THEM NAME,
BOB IGER,
IT'S HIS FAULT HE IS LOSING ALL
THIS MONEY AND HE IS GOING TO
HAVE TO PAY THE PRICE.
HE SAID THAT ON STAGE.
IT'S NOT A PUBLIC COMPANY.
IT'S HIS COMPANY.
CAN AFFORD TO KEEP DOING THIS.
>> WE GOT TO GO.
GREAT POINT.
KEYING ON THE IGER COMMENT,
WHICH I DON'T THINK HAS GOTTEN
AS MUCH ATTENTION AS IT SHOULD.
IT WAS A